Hey fuckers.
What'd you do?
I'm excited just talking about it.
This is the only better idea I've heard from you is our compound.
I want that's happening in compounds happening.
Aubrey's in Aubrey's done a better idea ever more realistic idea.
We'd have more realistic idea.
How can you say it's more realistic because we're not all going to like move our
families.
Oh No,
no,
no.
This you don't understand.
This is the latest idea.
The ladies idea is we get a set up.
Why did you make condos gate?
It was at one point in time,
kind of used to be a manly word.
To me,
point of success.
Well,
I've got a condo and I've got,
I can take her back to the condo.
I leased a BMW three series and joy.
Yet you specialize that word forever.
We've got,
do you realize that if you fall into a black hole,
you will see the entire future of the universe unfold in front of you and a
matter of moments and you will emerge into another space time created by the
singularity of the black hole you just fell into.
He just broke the,
broke the Hogan and that right there.
Can you imagine giving your son to someone to hack his balls off so he could
sing in a weird way?
People are so poor.
Back then it was like,
this is the only way out.
Oh my God.
Like opera was like white people's basketball like that.
You have a chance to be a constraint.
If you have any marijuana in your blood in Japan,
you're not gonna be able to fight.
So what did you get arrested for?
Marijuana.
So what,
how,
like what is it like,
is it like being caught with cocaine or
yeah,
to drugs.
That drug in Japan.
I was facing some bad time,
you know,
because uh,
I was a famous figure and they wanted to make an example to me.
So it was then the,
the interrogation came to finding out where I got my stuff in Japan,
if you throw everything to a foreign person,
they'll drop.
They won't want to go fight someone in America.
I,
I told him it was a student from Guam and just they asked me for a name and I
said,
Tony,
I knew like three Tonys and Guam,
so
keep it real.
We had like two days of questioning and late,
like the third day they said,
so happened caught me off guard man.
And the SP,
what's Tony's last name and this fricken ridiculous,
the first name that popped the males Montana
read when I said,
Oh fuck if these guys watch scarf
[inaudible]
see I'm screwed,
you know,
screwed.
Because they'll start the all over if
I get kick on an ally.
Right,
right,
right.
So he just,
I saw him write it down in Japanese in Montana and then he just started down and
I was like,
car face.
Not that popular.
I don't think it's that popular there.
Yeah.
But how long was it was worth the trip in
you?
I hug all my friends.
Right.
This is the most awkward guy ever.
He's like,
Yo,
shell the title.
But he's like,
he,
he wasn't there.
Alright.
Jesus.
That lazy gentleman was a gas moment in our podcast.
My belief is all of us have all of us create what we need to work through to
create and learn what we need to in this world.
And so I can't look at anyone as a victim.
I can't even a child.
I don't blame them.
I don't say,
this is your fault.
I say,
you made an agreement
in this place to do this and I am sending you all my love and I believe in you
and I believe that you will.
You can be a miracle.
Okay?
I mean like who's to say how you should live this life?
It's fucking,
I'll do it.
It's temporary.
Oreo,
right?
Oh,
you should be the ones who are wondering totally down.
Let's just start with you over that.
We should start with you and examine,
examine your,
your behavior at the Tsa.
I say I can't do it.
Medical condition.
Okay,
go this way.
Okay.
If they say,
are you opting out?
I was like,
I don't know what that means.
When I say,
do you not want that or do you want a pat down on?
I don't know.
I don't want to pat down,
but I'm not doing that thing.
So what am I options?
He's just trying to be Larry David.
No,
I'm just trying to not let them take away these freedoms from me without going
down with a little bit of a fight.
But you had Kimbo in fucking side control.
You work to get it.
You got,
you were a dominant position.
He was tired and they stood you back up bitches.
We did a,
um,
a video interview,
you know,
where everyone is on the other line.
And I've just finished training,
so I'm on the phone.
I want to,
no one was asking me fucking any questions.
Um,
and I thought,
yeah,
I'm just the guy.
Kimbo tepee.
So Amanda,
someone asked,
go show a question.
They said,
um,
what would you do with James Thompson won?
And he said,
I'd hung myself.
And I thought,
wow.
Okay.
What's the most money you've ever gambled the most I've ever lost in one night?
Yeah.
$8 tomorrow.
Okay.
What's the most you've ever lost someone?
1 million bucks.
Oh my.
Oh
my.
How much is it?
What's the most you've ever won?
6 million.
Okay.
Oh,
oh
Jesus.
Is it true that the reason why we don't go back to the palms,
it's because they cut back your a,
your gambling budget because you were killing him.
I go,
yeah.
Really?
Yeah.
That seems ridiculous.
I got into,
but that's the way Vegas says now.
I mean,
I guess the one film,
I recommend that everyone is Killa season.
All the dips said dudes are in it.
It's like the worst made [inaudible].
Oh,
you don't listen to the Dipset.
she's,
anyone here does ongoing shit.
What the dip set is?
Yo,
y'all don't know the dip set.
Y'All don't know the dip.
My grandfather's rolling over,
man.
I tell you these fucking kids today.
Wow.
Okay.
That little pink freak me out.
Gucci Mane is crazy.
Look at him.
He put an ice cream cone on his face.
It says burr.
You see it?
You see it on the cone.
Be Our,
our,
our and the taxi guy.
I was like,
okay,
call it ice.
Matt,
could you could you,
um,
I want,
I'm going to get,
have to get you to request this on video and then I need you to get,
I need you to write this down.
Come on man.
Just tattoo it.
I ain't gonna change my mind on my face,
man.
I want a cone.
A good one.
Like a waffle type motherfucker scrape.
Craziest par lightening bolt on my ice cream.
It looks like it under his,
I said something.
What the fuck?
Bop.
Honda's.
But yeah,
that dude is probably irrational.
Gucci Kiyoshi No,
Tom Day.
No hotel guys try.
What did you just look at?
Hartford teacher.
Got It.
What does that,
it's from gangster movies and shit.
Do you think you're talking
Ruskin?
I didn't do this to be mean.
I just did this because that's my nature.
I am the Scorpion.
You are the frog.
This is how shit goes down.
Matt.
Just tell him you love him.
Matt,
have you ever watched a Rodeo and felt sorry for the bowls?
Nothing.
One of the stories he tells us about this,
uh,
Eskimo guy,
old guy.
And the family sort of took the keys to the car away from him that like you
can't go anymore.
They were afraid he would go out and die the traditional way.
When Eskimo people got old,
they were just like wander off into the ice and die,
so as not to be a burden to the family.
And so that night he goes out,
it gets out of the house,
takes a shit in his hand,
forms the shit into a knife,
blade spits on it and the spit a is freezing along the edge and he hones that
down.
So he gets a nice sharp edge with his sped,
takes his shit knife,
kills a dog or a couple of dogs and takes their,
uh,
ribs and makes us a sled out of it.
And with the sinews and whatever other pieces of the dogs hooks up a couple
other dogs to the sled and he takes off into the,
into the snow on his,
you know,
sled with his shit knife.
Wow.
Oh my God.
That might be the most of the same story I've ever heard.
I had a,
I had an incident,
uh,
on a,
on the airplane going to Indianapolis where this,
this guy,
like I just guy just started like interrogating me.
He thought it was some sort of flight risk.
It just sitting there and he just says,
he goes,
hey,
you were you afraid to fly?
And he goes,
how could he goes out?
Why?
Why are you going to Indianapolis Bill?
I'm like,
yeah,
I don't have to answer your questions.
He goes,
you don't answer my questions right now.
I'm going to hit that call button.
I will stop this plane and you will be fucking arrested.
Like saying all this stuff and I'm just sitting there and he's yapping in my
ear.
He was,
you thinks this is fucking over there with a blindfold on laughing at him.
It was driving him fucking nuts.
It was great riding them starting to nod off.
I just hear why he'd go into Indianapolis spill.
I just laugh.
There's certain people that they have music laying around just because it's
cool.
I'm tons of them.
The worst being the Tom Waits era.
Those motherfuckers are ones I want to punch him right in the fucking face
because they're the ones you having a good time listening to something your
Bible and they want to like really impressed like some fucking dumped chick with
freckles or something.
Everybody's fucked already.
Know what I'm saying?
Everybody fucked all.
You need this Tequila and a gram of blow.
She'll be sucking your dick in a fucking bathroom.
You want to be cool and let's the Tom Waits.
Everyone's a time.
Wait.
Um,
yeah,
I don't like it.
That's good thing.
And you want that you're fucking idiot.
But the only reason that people would put that shit on is to try to overpower
you with that fucking star wars.
What do you call that?
The fucking thing with the mind.
The Mind Jack.
That's it.
Oh,
he's so,
oh my God.
He likes Tom.
Wait,
listen to that.
They're trying to shut you down with a gun next to your head.
You're telling me if that's true.
That's good.
Fucking second.
That's the Beatles.
Y'All fucking shoot.
You can put a gun to your bucket at all.
Right.
Telling me that's good music.
You're fucking 20 years old.
Not at all.
Like when somebody says I like the Dave Matthews Band,
I will pistol whip you.
He's beauty.
He just find my yard.
I swear he is to look at me.
He was my friend.
I know that sounds retarded.
But you are afraid of aliens though,
right?
Yeah.
My first a path mapped out in your house had to get out of the aliens show up.
That's the rumor man.
That's heard.
I
heard you have a plan because I know you like to use game plans,
so I figured he's had an alien.
I know,
I know cat ready and I know Jujitsu all didn't show up.
I put a triangle choke on him and I also have,
I kept that as well,
so I kept that to a Japanese get,
I'll see if they come,
I can slice them apart.
You've um,
you've kicked the green bitch.
Yes.
After a 24 year intense relationship with the,
uh,
the green goddess or the Green Bitch,
depending on what mood she's in.
I had to stop.
Um,
and uh,
I've come in for some,
I've convinced for some,
some criticism for this and I feel it's important to say that,
uh,
I hugely value and love cannabis.
I think it's a wonderful herbal ally and I think that,
I don't think that I would ever have written my books off historical mystery if
I had not encountered cannabis.
But like you mean you guys are both in better shape than I am,
but I work out 45 minutes a month.
I do my whole body vibration 45 minutes a month.
I'm not kidding.
I do high end had a minute less ridiculous.
That's five times more than me.
Really?
You too busy.
I have some theories about that I was doing,
I invented bulletproof intermittent fasting during that time,
which is when you do bulletproof coffee during an intermittent fast,
I'm sorry,
but you could be a hilarious Saturday night live sketch too.
You get any more famous,
you're in trouble because we didn't do a sketch where everything,
I'm going to take a bulletproof shit.
Then I'm going to get my bullet proof car and go to the bulletproof office.
You know,
this is my bulletproof secretary.
I'll stop bulletproofing stuff,
Joe,
but no more.
All right,
fair enough.
I got a buddy who's a billionaire,
real live billionaire.
So
years later he came into the money like where it was his in one year he went
from fucking Zenith,
the Nadir,
like he,
he straight to Rehab.
He was,
he would call me and be like,
I'm in Vegas.
I've got the top floor of the wind rented.
I get slip and slides down the hallway.
There's,
there's strippers and hookers everywhere.
And we got midgets in a storm trooper outfit serving a strengths and he'd be
like,
all of a private jet picking you up.
Get here.
Now how much money did he inherit?
A bout $5 billion.
Oh my goodness.
And he's not fun anymore.
It's the best clip.
All right,
we'll do this.
And you see kids running with their elbows out,
right.
Like RTD too.
Two.
Right.
That's a test.
That's c three Po runs with his arms out.
Yeah.
What is the r two d two doesn't have arms.
I'm just letting you talk to him.
All right.
I'll try
to stay in your hair.
I'm fine.
The Opening Act upchuck uh,
the clown is trying to calm my nerves now.
There's,
there's no,
you know,
they have their,
their,
their own security.
So there's no security.
It's just,
it's just juggle a law and this huge piece of property up trying to convince me
that it's not that scary of a Gig.
And he's driving me around on this golf cart and he's like,
you know,
you got it.
And this huge cloud,
just,
this guy just jumps out of nowhere and starts punching up chuck.
I'm the golf guy.
He's running along and it ain't for no reason.
He's like,
fuck you.
Fuck you.
I'm in shock.
And he just hit a day.
Yeah.
And he's gunning it and the guy said,
we lose the game.
And he's like,
ah,
I'm here every year.
You know,
they know me,
I'm like family.
And I'm like,
okay.
So He's trying to convince me this can affect the first kind of fake what comes
in and it just sprays all over us.
And uh,
and he's like,
he's so familiar with getting hit with Paygo Cola.
He goes,
he goes,
uh,
it's diet.
It's not going to stay.
I swear to God.
Then one comes in and in the o nine,
he's got it on camera.
It's like the Zapruder film.
We got this can of soda.
This guy does a baseball pitch and you see it whizzing seconds before it hits
the temple.
No.
[inaudible] it's lump sum for the wheel.
And he goes,
I'm hurt.
I'm hurt bad by the way.
He's mid sentence,
I guess,
you know,
something like that.
When the soda,
is that going to happen at a Dave Matthews correc and slump.
So He's like,
I'm hurt.
I'm hurt bad Bob.
He's calling me Bob.
So I know he's really fucked up,
not bobcat.
We walk in and you know,
everyone's gone,
but Sam and like three other people and they're still doing blow.
I first walked into the kitchen and walked back to the room.
I see the doors open.
All the guitars are gone.
My bed's fucked up.
Like the door had been broken and kicked in and Sam looks at me and goes up
pissed on your bed.
Mer,
you want to know why?
And I go,
yeah,
yeah I do.
He goes,
cause you at that fucking moron.
Sleep with my guitars.
And like,
then there's this word silence.
And I turned to bill and I said,
I told you I knew him.
Huh?
I could do John Mayer did to too.
No,
I think he's great.
I think he's very talented.
But if your wife is really into going,
you know what I'm saying?
Like she dragged you there and just stares at him.
Right?
Boob bless you.
Notice she's not clapping because when her hands slipped down her genes,
she's his knuckle deep.
Oh,
so sad.
It sounds like someone's stabbing of seal.
Just
she's just Fiserv herself.
She's all the way to her elbow.
Just grounded it in there.
You can see her rib cage expand as a fist.
Goes up there
fucking love you.
Okay.
Let's go.
And if you break down humor like that,
like you said,
fine tooth comb,
every single joke where 90% of the jokes you do,
unless you're talking about balloons are bouncing a ball,
have hurt somebody.
If we get that literal with humor than almost all jokes comics tell are going to
be up for a a careful examination.
Contributing to a fucking rape culture is nonsense and it is to say comedian
contributes to rape culture is simply bullshit and it's simplistic thinking.
It's a way of saying,
I don't like what you're saying and I don't want you to say it,
but I can't come out with that.
So I have to find a higher reason which makes it sound like you shouldn't say
it.
For this reason,
as the ban against these weapons roads,
other tyrants will have no reason to think twice about acquiring poison gas and
using them cheeses over time where the troops were again,
face the prospect.
Honestly,
we don't attack the area.
I'm going to get some poison gas.
It could be easier for terrorist organizations and the day after any military
action,
we would redouble our efforts to achieve a political solution that strengthens
those who reject the forces of tyranny and extremism.
Biden beat me at poker.
He used to run Raytheon.
They sell how?
Hellfire missiles.
Oh,
now he's leaving.
The same way came in.
Oh my God.
Nice and dramatic that just that alone,
all of this ready attrical shit was orchestrated.
Folks,
I guarantee you there are some people that are involved in this.
There's some producers,
there's some,
there's an artistic director they want.
That was a,
that was a well planned out scene.
He walks up,
he walks back.
The fact that they do it in this ancient stupid house where he supposedly lives.
Meanwhile,
you know he's in some fucking seven mile thick bunker down deep into the ground.
The bowels of the Earth where Dick Cheney was hiding all throughout the Iraq
war.
I remember,
here's just a metal slide he jumps in and look at.
It's a shoot,
like a laundry chute,
jumps in and slides through the lens and the towels and just go some cell phone
off and surrounded by lizards who are like excellent work.
Yeah,
it's bad.
It's about men's layer.
How much time between her putting the Saran wrap over your butt hole and you
shooting a load,
how much time fit?
15 seconds to put the Saran wrap,
five seconds to shoot.
Gosh,
you know what I mean?
It's,
it's horrendous.
I mean you call it feminism Marxists with pennies.
Does that socialism,
socialism,
socialism at test,
but that was a bad character and one of my novels,
I just go on the feminism.
Socialism at Penn is that is very true because I mean,
and then people call,
oh my God,
that's so terrible.
That's not,
I just went through all the founding matriarchs of the feminist system that all
Marxists,
all leftist and so on and also it feminist is so pro woman then where are they
with Margaret Thatcher?
Margaret Thatcher was like the first leader of a Western country.
She struggled that from nothing.
I made an incredibly powerful woman,
but she was on the right.
You see,
so they hate her.
What about Iran?
I ran,
wrote,
wrote the most influential book outside the Bible and the second most
influential book and according to The New York Times review of books after the
Bible,
uh,
you know,
we shaped a western philosophy in many ways and western politics and the
feminist hater.
Why?
Cause she was on the right cause he's,
that's what they think.
She was not actually on the right,
but so I mean I have these sorts of suspicions when they're sort of the,
is it the leftist ideology or the pro woman?
Now if it's the pro woman,
then they should be incredibly positive.
Where are the feminists when people insult people like Ann Coulter,
where are the feminist?
When people insult Sarah Pailin,
you don't like Bill Maher,
her called her a cunt.
I mean that's really pretty vicious.
Like publicly,
openly,
right?
I mean where are the fee because they are on the rise and culture and they're
considered to be on the right.
So they get a pass when people go,
you know,
but you then say something bad about a woman on the left.
And so I think that he is more left than it is pro women because when they
choose between their politics and the agenda,
they always seem to choose the politics of what the agenda is.
And that's why I say it's left as rather than then problem.
Right.
People always take things at face value.
They don't tend to get to know you or,
I mean I'm sitting right in front of you now.
Would you say that I am a woman?
No,
no.
Don't say you're a woman.
Thank you.
Have a beard.
Beard.
Yeah.
No,
you're basically a man.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
No problem.
Be Compliment from
people.
Steal everything you see this is,
yeah,
this is awesome.
Yeah,
I saw that.
You see that on fucking unbelievable.
Joey's in a far right.
That's insane.
That would look at when we were so cute.
I got the sexy lucky seven.
Can you get it?
So it just as whole body feels is chrome was 44 I was 44 there was local lucky
seven cause I like that.
Look at that.
Wow,
that's so crazy.
Wow.
Look at you dude.
So how old are you in this picture?
14.
14 and that's what I was noticing.
I was smoking dope then.
I was no innocent then I was smoking dope.
I was finger bang.
And people,
the hardest thing in the world is to say,
if somebody says to you,
relax,
right,
or be yourself,
it just be yourself,
Joe.
You know?
I mean,
and,
and yet I think as we become more professional and better at what we're doing,
when somebody says to you,
be yourself,
you can,
you know,
you're not burdened by these false selves and these things that,
uh,
that you think you ought to be or ought block to say,
or how you want to look or what you ought to be.
And I think in many ways that's what any artist does as they become a
professional at what they do.
They learned to kind of get out of their own way.
And it's the hardest thing of all,
I think.
Do you feel a responsibility for that or towards that as an artist?
Do you ever feel like because of the,
what you're doing,
because if you're,
you're so motivated,
you get so much done and you have so many different projects going.
Do you,
do you realize the impact of that?
Because a lot of people were inspired by though the,
not just the work ethic that you have,
but the,
how much quality shit you produce,
whether it's wine or music or,
I appreciate the company.
Um,
I think,
I think you can't really worry about it.
You just got to do what it is doing.
And for me,
I just have to do what I'm doing.
And there's a,
there's a,
there's a sense of,
for the art or for the,
the process.
And just for myself,
I just,
I care about what I'm doing.
Um,
if I start caring about what you think about what I'm doing,
whether it's going to be helping you,
then I'm,
uh,
that I'm,
an assisted living,
uh,
employee when I was on the space station the second time.
One of the other crew members,
her name is sue Holmes.
Uh,
she and I were talking,
we'd known each other since test pilot school.
And in passing a throwaway thing,
she didn't even think she was saying.
She said,
hey,
you know,
Earth said that we're supposed to do this next.
And in my mind,
I heard Earth said,
I heard those words come out of her mouth.
And it was like,
she has in her mind completely a split off from the other 7 billion people.
There's her crew and earth is one singular identifiable entity on the other
side.
And that was a real,
a bellringer to me of what it's going to be like to go to Mars.
Those people are going to be,
uh,
a completely discrete unit of people and there'll be Martians.
They won't be earthlinks pretty quick in their heads.
And how do you deal with that?
How do we plan for that?
And it's still a long ways in the future,
but it's one of the many things we need to sort out before we,
because as you say,
once you get the engines going fast enough that you're,
you're headed for Mars,
you can't just turn around.
I think we're not talking an attorney.
Right?
Yeah.
And in Houston I was an attorney then in Dallas I started a computer company.
I had a personal computer company that uh,
well in 1981 we outgrowth Microsoft,
you know,
I had four color picture in Forbes magazine,
made the front page of the Wall Street Journal and really then IBM came in and
crushed us like a bug.
Wow.
We just sort of sold ourselves out of business and by the time we were done the
last six,
eight,
nine months,
I was financing the thing by selling ecstasy.
What's,
and I know a guy,
my acting class and you know how long I was an acting class years.
There was a guy,
really good guy,
normal guy.
So I thought,
and he was,
and I hired him to shoot me to shoot this audition.
So I go to his house and he's got this great camera and on his wall is a dream
board and on his wall is his,
no,
no.
He's put his face.
He's put his face on the cover of vanity fair and those magazines,
he's got slogan's saying,
you're the guy,
you're the one and it's a dream board.
And it was big.
It was good.
Covered his whole wall,
man.
Yes,
you should dream big,
but you should also be realistic with who you are.
I won't do it.
He's gonna do it.
Shit.
He could put his hand between my legs and roll me back.
Right.
But see that way you'll get,
don't let him see you doing that.
He's going to hurt you.
What does this 10% you keep saying,
why do you keep saying 10%?
Well,
Brian keeps saying 10%.
It's a running joke based in truth.
I had some issues.
I had some situations in my life and I,
I like to put numbers on things and based
on these factors and experiences and thought processes,
we came to the number of,
uh,
10% gay.
I'm open with it.
You know it it,
it's not,
what'd she just say it?
It's not,
I understand what you just said.
What you just said was a statement that would really work if everybody knew what
you were saying,
but I don't know what you're saying.
So what you're saying is a 10% gay.
I'm open with it.
What does that mean?
Does that mean you're 10% gay?
Yes.
I came out on my podcast probably like six months ago.
You came out 10% yes.
So funny.
Is there any beers in there?
Jamie?
Go get me a beer.
I need a beer on this one.
Yeah,
this is going to get rid of,
you know,
this is insane.
I just want to point something out of how we are so weird like as a culture that
this is a part of like normal everyday office life.
Like we've got to make some decisions here.
Like okay look at this woman.
She's showing everything but her vagina,
I mean her knee is just strategically blocking her Lavia her legs are wide open
and she's hot as fuck.
Now here's the thing.
If you put the Kyron right in front of the vagina,
then everybody would know the news.
Exactly.
We'd be a very informed country and women would get angry at you if you knew the
news.
Oh,
you were looking at her vagina and you read the fucking news.
Huh?
This is like something that I liked that Ron doss has,
which is like if you don't feel like meditating,
don't meditate.
Don't force it.
Don't impose this on yourself.
Keep doing the thing you're doing that's upsetting you so much.
Have the balls to keep doing the fucking thing that you're doing.
Keep doing it.
If society is going to tell you,
don't be like this.
Stop being like this.
You'd have to change.
That's what your parents always say.
The idea is like no,
sink into what you are right now.
Just be that thing.
Stop resisting exactly where you are right now is perfect.
And that's a hard truth to grasp.
I've been listening to a Dan Carlin and barbecue my ass.
Dan Carlin was uh,
the um,
uh,
the,
our,
our guests on Monday and he has a podcast called hardcore history.
Yeah.
And right now it's all about the Mongols.
And for the next hour home,
I listened to the history of the Mongol Empire,
uh,
which is fascinating.
Dan Carlin's hardcore history.
Um,
I'm really into this,
I'm Dan Carlin,
a podcast recently.
He's got this podcast called hardcore history and uh,
he does this really detailed history of the Mongols over like five,
five episodes.
Well,
I told you I'm a fucking in love with that.
Dan Carlin's hardcore history podcast.
You know,
that's one of the really cool things.
This Dan Carlin thing on,
um,
uh,
on the history of the Mongols.
You know,
we had Dan Carlin on from hardcore history.
You're listening to that podcast.
I have heard about it from one of his most bad ass podcasts is about the
Mongols.
Kingus Khan was a mother fucker.
Like he definitely killed 10 million.
God Damn,
that's unbelievable.
That's,
that's the best talking about armies that were coming towards China where the
Mongols had been in the distance.
They thought they saw snow covered mountains,
but when they got close they realized they were mounds of bones.
Oh my God.
And garlic and the garlic is just gangster,
just killing everybody.
Anybody that's anywhere,
it's like the Mongol hoards.
It's like something out of ancient times that we have that,
you know,
Jeff,
it's like a Mongo whore.
Right,
exactly.
That's pretty preposterous.
The world has actually never been less violent than it is today.
Look at Syria,
how 100,000 people like,
and it's a lot,
but I guess she used to be worried.
I mean the Mongols killed a million and a half,
right?
There's a lot less murder.
Then there was like in the fucking 12 hundreds back during the Mongol days and
shit like that.
Brian blog,
go to my Twitter and uh,
there's a thing that I retweeted earlier today from Dan Carlin,
a hardcore history guy.
He,
uh,
put up a trailer of a Gingiss Khan and the Mongols from like the John Wayne era.
They did a movie with John [inaudible] is con the Concord.
Everybody,
the Mongols came through Moscow in the winter.
They came through the,
through the fucking attacked Russia in the winter because nobody else would do
it that way.
And they didn't eat.
They didn't see it coming.
Did I tell you how they,
why they were so hard to follow into the desert?
Who the mom calls.
You didn't have to tell me.
I know a lot about them,
but go ahead if you want to.
Well it's just what,
are you a fucking educator now?
Because did I tell you,
cause they were like,
if we get some Saturdays to get their arms together,
I don't have,
I have I briefed you on the model.
It's my friend.
I'm going to do,
I'm glad you asked.
I think we talked last time about how there was,
there was,
there's pictures of,
uh,
of Afghanistan with,
with Western ideal type Western idea type cultures.
Uh,
you know,
there was a massive culture shift in terms of,
women with education and your state of dress and,
and things wouldn't be allowed.
Well,
there was a fantastic episode of hardcore history and the Dan Carlin podcast
where he talked about the Mongols invading Iraq.
Well,
this is the second time that someone has done that to Baghdad.
It's a,
I've been listening to for the past couple of years.
Dan Carlin's hardcore history.
When Baghdad was raided by the Mongols and they crushed the society,
they basically started from scratch after that kills everyone and through all
the literature away so that they save it today,
they're just getting to the point like culturally of where they were in 2012 and
the Mongols were throwing trees at them.
They cut all their trees down and then they stacked them up with giant catapult
and hurled them over the gates.
Just Shroyer everything in the city and what they would do is take the survivors
and put them in the front lines and use them.
Oftentimes as the front.
They would push an army into the town and people would be shooting arrows at
their own friends.
Thousands and thousands of people just be forced through the door of a,
of,
of a,
of the gate of a,
of a city.
I listened to your Mongo podcast at least four or five times what I called the
Joe Rogan stopped telling Joe Rogan to talk about your mom goal podcast on his
shoe.
You talked to this poor comedic woman about it and you said something and there
was,
we went back to her.
There's this long dead silence where she tried to absorb what you just told her.
Who was that?
Who Do you think that would have been a female comedian?
She said I've got a show on consumer.
Yeah,
that's most likely about it.
There's this long pause like what do I say after that?
Yeah I can,
Amy Schumer was some fucking crazy
man.
I must be broadcasting to record.
What the fuck I am broadcasting.
He cuts.
There we go now.
Now we're on ladies and gentlemen,
we're sort of on time.
Ah
We try to get it right every week,
but every week we fucked something up and this week I made sure that I turned
off the sound on my computer.
The one over there,
I haven't even turned off the sound on this one yet.
So for you,
he did four years.
You got mine do mine.
He didn't do yours pass the torch.
It could've easily been me.
That just fucked up.
Which is,
that's the reason why I fucked up.
It's cause cause I'm here cause I always fuck it up.
I fucked it up every week we'd done this God damn thing like 22 weeks in a row.
I fuck it up every single time for this week.
It was Brian,
you know,
uh,
I've been thinking about this podcast a lot,
ladies and gentlemen and a,
one of the things I've been thinking about it is I appreciate the fuck out of
everybody listening.
And uh,
we,
we do try our best to make this as interesting as possible and as smooth and
professional as possible.
But I got admit that I've been too stressed out about this.
I've been taking it too seriously.
I mean,
uh,
taking seriously in a good way where as we improve the sound,
we've got a real mixer and we got to,
I mean we're sitting on couches and shit and we're going to get it better
cameras,
but that like,
it's not like there's a part of it,
it's really fun,
but there's a part of it that wasn't fun and I don't think that should exist.
I don't think I should ever get too serious about this.
This is for people who are working,
who are being distracted that just wants something because they're doing
mindless shit.
This is for people that are driving in their cars and you know,
wants up to now listen to this is for people on the train.
This is for people at the gym,
whatever the fuck it's for you guys.
All right.
And if,
if we take it too seriously,
you stop being yourself and it starts,
starts being like this professional thing that you're trying real hard to do.
And uh,
I think,
uh,
I think I've fallen prey to that a little bit.
I was thinking about it today after to took a little bit of the head of the weed
and I was thinking about it and I was like,
you know what man,
this thing,
like I'm,
I'm like,
Aye.
I paid too much attention to it and she'd just be a weekly fun thing like it or
not,
you know,
for,
for anybody who's a likeminded or anybody is interested in some sort of a
distraction from someone who's not likeminded.
Um,
so thank you very much for tuning in.
Everybody.
Love you.
Bitches mitre
right.